today's episode is brought to you by
curiositystream curiositystream is a
subscription streaming service that
offers thousands of fascinating
documentaries and non-fiction titles
from some of the world's best filmmakers
including exclusive originals no reality
show nonsense here just non-fiction
entertainment enjoyed by millions
curiosity streams available on many
platforms web app roku android xbox one
smart tvs ios chromecast amazon fire
amazon kindle and apple tv and it's also
available worldwide now look if you like
my channel since i imagine you might
since you're watching it right now hello
you can head over to curiositystream and
check out their docu-series history by
the numbers it's a very interesting
series that talks about some of the
people that we've covered here on
biographics as well as some of the
places we've talked about over on our
sister channel geographics is great
crossover potential you can go to
curiositystream.com forward slash
biographics for unlimited access to the
world's top documentaries and
non-fiction series and right now you
guys can use the promo code biographics
and you'll save 25 off the cost of an
annual subscription which comes out to
only 14.99 a year which is a crazy good
deal so click below or go to
curiositystream.combiographics
and save 25
right now making it just 14.99 for the
whole year and now today's video
on the morning of april 28 1908
everything changed for the small city of
la porte indiana during the night a fire
erupted at the gunners homestead and
burned the farmhouse to the grounds
along with everybody in sight the
charred remains of four people were
recovered from the smoldering ruins one
woman and three young children clearly
what had happened was that bergunus the
widow who owned the property had
perished trying to save her children the
whole town decried the loss of one of
their own a heroic woman who sacrificed
a life for a family the police had a
more sinister idea in mind the woman's
body had been found headless so
unsurprisingly they suspected foul play
they thought that a former farmhand
named ray lamphia might be worth looking
into fearing that he could have killed
belle gunness and then staged the fire
to hide his murderous deed even so in
the minds of everyone bell gunness was
still the victim here but that image
would soon be shattered as investigators
kept digging around the property looking
for a skull one day almost a week after
the blaze diggers explored a small mound
of fresh earth in the pigpens and
uncovered a gunny sack buried under a
layer of trash inside the bag two hands
two feet and one head all belonged to
the same man and all had been chopped up
with an axe a slow sensation of dread
crept over the investigators as they
realized that dozens of similar mounds
were strewn across the pigpens they
started digging them all up and each one
yielded remains from another victim the
true extent of the horror that went on
at that homestead was soon apparent for
years belle gunners had been using her
farmhouse as the location where she
killed dismembered and buried her
victims all of a sudden nobody was
singing her praises anymore as people
saw belle gunners for what she truly was
one of the most vicious murderers in the
history of the united states
[Music]
belgiumis was born bryn hild paul's
death starset on november 11 1859 in the
municipality of selbu norway the
daughter of paul and barrett's dorset
her father worked as a stonemason and he
expected all of his children to pitch in
and help keep the family farm going
therefore bell got used to hard work
from an early age and when she got older
she was hired by a wealthy family to
work on their farm as well fortunately
for belle she was a physically strong
woman so she never shied away from
annual labor since her early life is
poorly documented it's a little hard to
pinpoint any reason for belle gunner's
murderous actions her childhood wasn't
exactly a walk in the park but it wasn't
please sir i want some more there is one
story but it remains unverified which
claims that belle got pregnant when she
was 18 and that she attended a dance
where she was attacked and kicked in the
stomach the attack caused her to have a
miscarriage and to make matters worse
her assailant got off scot-free because
he came from a wealthy and influential
family soon afterward karma took matters
into his own hands and gave the man
stomach cancer but the whole ordeal left
belle gunus a different woman her
friends and family said that outwardly
her personality and behavior changed
drastically while inwardly it is
possible that she started harboring a
vicious resentment towards those around
her as we said this might be a story but
it could provide bell gunners with a
motive for her killings besides the
allure of easy riches either way a
couple years later belle got the
opportunity to move to america her older
sister anna had left years earlier and
married a man named john larson in
chicago and started a new life in 1881
she asked belle to join her and the 22
year old woman jumped at the opportunity
later that same year bell gunners left
norway and made her way to chicago to
live with her sister there she
discovered a familiar setting full of
the same traditions and culture she'd
left behind because anna and her husband
lived in a close-knit scandinavian
community a short while later belle met
a man named mad sorensen who worked as a
night watchman at the department store
the two got married in 1884 and had a
seemingly happy marriage for the next
decade and a half they had four or five
children together most likely foster
kids adopted from poor families but two
of them did not live past infancy
details on their demise are scarce it
believed that they both suffered from
acute colitis but the symptoms of the
disease could have been caused by
various poisons as well as you'll soon
find out they would not be the only
children to perish under belle's care so
were they simply victims of an
unfortunate illness or were they the
first to fall prey to belle gunness's
cold and callous murder spree either way
gunness was able to outwardly project
the image of a good wife and mother who
was kind and doting on the people in her
life nobody in the neighborhood
suspected that something more sinister
could have been lurking beneath
[Music]
there's not much to say about belle's
marriage to sorensen one thing to
mention is that the family seemed to be
plagued by fires the house burned down
on one occasion although nobody was
injured on another occasion the candy
store that the sorensens owned and
operated also burned down both times the
buildings were insured and the insurance
companies paid out even though they
suspected arsenal as a possibility some
could say that this was simply a string
of misfortunes and the fires were not
incredibly uncommon back then others
would see it for what it probably was a
criminal perfecting her modus operandi
the only real question here is whether
or not mad sorensen was in on the scam
if he was truly aware of the kind of
woman he had married that he probably
should have been a bit more reticent to
take out large life insurance policies
on himself given how much his wife liked
a big juicy cash payout but in 1900 matt
sorensen had a 2 000 policy that was
about to expire and he already took out
a new one worth even more 3 000 the new
life insurance policy kicked in on the
same day that the old one expired july
the 30th 1900 that meant for one day and
one day only mad sorensen was covered by
both policies worth a cool five grand
and wouldn't you know it that's exactly
the day he fell mortally ill by a
complete happenstance with no outside
interference whatsoever his cause of
death is a bit uncertain maybe a heart
attack may be a cerebral hemorrhage
according to gunness husband came home
complaining of a terrible headache so
she gave him quinine powder and he died
a while later while she was in the
kitchen making dinner some suspected
that the pharmacist may have
accidentally given gunners morphine
instead of quinnine but she had thrown
away the paper so nobody could check
others including torrent and family even
accused bell of poisoning her husband
since the timing was just so damn
convenient but ultimately the family
doctor deemed the death natural causes
and bell gunners got her insurance
company to shut up the big bucks for
both life policies flush with cash the
new widow decided it was time to seek
greener pastures perhaps by now her
neighbors had begun noticing all the
tragedies that kept happening to
belganis and how they were always
followed by insurance payouts so in 1901
she left chicago with her three
remaining daughters myrtle jenny and
lucy and purchased a farm on the
outskirts of laporte indiana shortly
after the move bell met a butcher named
peter gunnis himself a recent widower
the two got married in 1902 and almost
immediately tragedy struck when peter's
infant daughter died on the mysterious
circumstances while in the care of a new
stepmother peter gunnis did not have a
lot of time to grieve because around a
year and a half later he met his own
demise when his skull was caved in by
something really heavy jenny walked into
the kitchen to find peter goddess
slumped on the floor bleeding from his
head while belle was standing over him
and crying a story was that a sausage
grinder topped off a high shelf and fell
right onto his head and even though
officials found the story a little
strange ultimately they ruled peter
gunnis's demise to be an accident the
death was far more gruesome and violent
than the others so be the bell gunners
decided to mix up her killing methods to
make it less obvious or there was a
small teeny tiny chance that this was a
genuine accident it's still probably the
former though especially since peter's
death came with another profitable
insurance policy payout for his family
even if she fooled the authorities
clearly not everyone in her life
believed belgurus her late husband had
an older daughter named swan hild and
peter's brother decided that she would
be better off living with him than with
belle so he took her to wisconsin and
thus she became the only child in
belguna's care to survive her wicked
stepmother as far as we can tell the
next one to go was jenny olson belle's
foster child jenny started spreading
rumors around school that her mama
killed her papa so she had to go around
1906 she simply disappeared and everyone
believed belle when she told them that
jenny went to california to study at a
lutheran college they wouldn't see the
girl again until the police started
digging up the yard of the gunness farm
looking for bodies
[Music]
around 1905 belgium has decided that she
had been widowed enough and that it was
time to look for another husband victim
her ideal suitor was a middle-aged
norwegian man of some means who wasn't
that close to his family so they
wouldn't come a calling when he had
inevitably went missing such prospects
were a bit thin on the ground in laporte
indiana so belle decided to expand her
search by placing ads in the personal
section of several norwegian language
newspapers this is what her enticing
announcement said personal comely widow
who owns a large farm in one of the
finest districts in la porte county
indiana desires to make the acquaintance
of a gentleman equally well provided
with view of joining fortunes no replies
by the considering lasender is willing
to follow answer with personal visit
triflers need not apply while we do not
know the identities of all of our
suitors we do know that over the next
three years bell gunners engaged in a
vicious killing spree that included at
least 10 victims and perhaps as many as
40 according to some estimates one of
them was henry gerhald a farmhand from
wisconsin he answered belle's personal
ad and visited her farm in laporte
indiana he liked what he saw so he wrote
to his family back in wisconsin telling
them that he's well and that they should
send him sweet potatoes afterward
gerhold never contacted them again and
when his family wrote to bell asking for
his whereabouts she simply told them
that he had gone off with horse traders
to chicago another example was john moe
from minnesota who went missing in 1906.
sometimes some of these men didn't bring
cash with them and instead they wired
the money to the bank in the port in
these cases gunners had to sweet talk
them a bit longer until they felt
comfortable enough to withdraw the money
from the bank once the cash was in
bell's hands the men were as good as
dead poison was gunnis's preferred
method of disposal afterwards she would
chop up the body put the torso in one
sack and the hands legs and head another
and bury them on the property soon
enough gunnis had amassed a nice little
nest deck each prospective suitor
brought at least a thousand dollars with
him and some brought double or triple
that by 1907 she slowed down with
personal ads instead she hired a local
carpenter named ray lamphia as her new
farmhand and they soon became lovers
however the two of them clearly
disagreed over the nature of their
relationship lamphia was broke and had
no prospect so he was hoping that he
would eventually marry garners and
become a partner in the farm belgium
however had no use for a man with no
money and for her lampare was just a bed
buddy to serve as a distraction by the
end of the year she had ended things
with him kicked him off the farm and
resumed her personal ads
[Music]
allegedly lampear began harassing
gunners and making threats that he would
burn her house down this is what bell
told her neighbors and she complained to
the sheriff and even had lampara
arrested for trespassing but was this a
legitimate danger posed by a scorned
lover or was it the plan of a devious
and clever mind to use him as a
scapegoat could it be that gunness's
entire relationship with lamphair was to
facilitate her disappearance and to turn
him into the perfect patsy by early 1908
belle found another suitor and she was
telling everyone that he might finally
be the one he was a burly wheat farmer
from south dakota named andrew helgelein
and it took dozens of letters to finally
persuade him to visit her in indiana
once he arrived in la porte belle turned
on the good old gunness charmer before
long halloween was withdrawing money out
of the bank so the two of them could
start a new life together a few days
later he was gone and bell was once
again playing the part of the jilted
lover who just doesn't have any luck
with men this time though things went a
bit differently because andrew halgerlin
had a brother named alsa who was a lot
more persistent than the other relatives
gunness had dealt with usler didn't even
know where his brother had gone but he
found a stack of letters between andrew
and bell gunnis kept mentioning in the
letters how andrew should take all of
his money out of the bank how he should
sell everything and leave dakota without
telling anyone what he is doing he
immediately feared that his brother had
been conned and to be honest the truly
surprising part was that none of the
other men who fell victim to gunners
found it suspicious at all like the
other relatives of the missing men asler
helgelin wrote to bell and inquired
about his brother she gave him the
standard response that andrew went to
chicago but this wasn't good enough
asler so he packed up his bags and
headed to indiana when oscar if belgonis
had any idea that asla helgelin was
coming her way or if she just had a
feeling that laporte was getting too hot
for her but on april 27th 1908 she
visited a lawyer and made a will once
again reiterating that she feared for
her life due to raelan fear that night
her house burned down seemingly killing
belle gunners and her three children to
nobody's surprise ray lampir was
arrested the following day but it did
not take long for doubts over his guilt
to spring up everybody in town had heard
about the gruesome circumstances of the
fire and that the burned woman was
missing her head at first glance that
sounded like the kind of thing a man
such as lampear would do out of rage but
rumors soon started spreading the body
was way too small to belong to the burly
200-pound bell gunness then as deputies
searched through the rubble looking for
the missing head they found odd things
collections of men's clothes men's
watches men's trunks all the sorts of
things that a man would travel with but
stuff that you would expect them to take
with them when they cleared out the fact
that they left everything behind
strongly suggested that none of them
ever departed the gunness farm at all a
few days after the fire asla helgeland
arrived in la porte and was given
permission by the sheriff to check the
farm for any clues to his brother's
whereabouts that same day farmhands
thought to dig one of the soft mounds
that was scattered all over the property
they found a gunny sack with the limbs
and head of a man hustler took one good
look and recognized the victim
immediately the head belonged to his
brother andrew
clearly something very very bad had
happened at the gunners farm but the
exact circumstances were still a bit of
a mystery did goddess kill and dismember
halgerlin did lamphia did they do it
together maybe they were some kind of
killer couple who lured and murdered
unsuspecting suitors for their money the
answer came in a few hours but the four
bodies were excavated that same day one
of them was positively identified as
jenny olsen a foster child who
supposedly traveled to california back
in 1906. obviously lam fear couldn't
have had anything to do with it since it
happened before he even stepped foot on
the farm steadily everyone began to
realize the kind of monster that belle
gunness truly was the next day the
nightmare got much worse as another six
bodies were dug up all of them had been
chopped up the same way and coupled with
the lime some contained traces of
strychnine while others showed signs of
large gashes and blunt trauma to the
head so it appears that gunnis sometimes
preferred to get her hands dirty instead
of letting the poison do all the work
after 11 bodies were found in just two
days the local police stopped keeping
track of how many new victims they
uncovered following the fire the sheriff
hoped to avoid too much publicity
surrounding the case but once the true
extent of the crimes became known there
was no way to prevent the murders from
turning into front-page news across the
country the media jumped at the
opportunity the gunness property was
called a death garden or a horror farm
while bella self-earned monikers such as
indiana ogris and the mistress of the
castle of death or even female bluebeard
overnight laporte indiana became
murdertown usa and thousands of tourists
flocked to the city each day to watch
the digging take place at the most
infamous farm in america all the inns
motels and hotels were booked
enterprising vendors sold everything
from gruesome photographs skull replicas
souvenirs that supposedly came from the
farm and even some kind of meat
concoction dubbed gonna stew many of the
remains were never identified but it
stands to reason that they were the men
who came to laporte hoping to find a
loving wife and instead found a cold
calculated and merciless predator the
body of a woman was dug up as was the
body of a young boy but neither one was
identified eventually people remembered
all the suspicious deaths in belle's
earlier life her two husbands and some
of the children in her care and realized
they should have been doing this for
even longer than they imagined even with
the murder spree out in the open there
were two issues still left to resolve
the first was reyla fear guilty of
anything the state prosecutor thought he
was or better yet he wanted him to be it
was only the illusion of justice but
officials wanted to show someone being
punished in a court of law for all the
murder and mayhem that went on the
sheriff's department desperately tried
to recover belle's skull because if she
was truly dead then that meant lymphe
killed her ultimately her skull was
nowhere to be found but they found some
gold teeth that the local dentist
identified as belle's dentures based on
that evidence the coroner proclaimed
belgunus to be dead of fearless homicide
and ray lamphia was indicted the trial
itself became as much of a media circus
as the murder investigation in the end
neither side could prove their point
beyond a shadow of a doubt so the jury
reached a strange compromise they found
lymphe guilty of arson but not murder he
was spared the hangman's noose but it
didn't make much difference lamphere
fell over tuberculosis and died in
prison just a year after the trial and
this brings us to the second and far
more interesting issue what really
happened to belle gunness was she really
decapitated and set on fire or did she
fake her death and put the blame on ray
lamphia many people believed the latter
and still believe it to this day after
all besides the fact that the mysterious
headless body was found in our home next
to her children there's no solid
evidence to indicate that it belonged to
bel gunnis and the fact that she visited
a lawyer the same day of the fire does
suggest some planning during lamphia's
trial his defense attorney even produced
a few witnesses who claimed to have seen
bell after the fire in fact such
sightings continued for years all the
way from down south to the east coast to
canada and even back to norway
everything is suggested but nothing is
conclusive officially belgonis was
recorded as being killed in that fire
however it is distinctly possible that
she killed dozens of people stole their
money and then got away with it living
out the rest of her life in anonymity
the true fate of belgutis
just remains a mystery to this very day
[Music]